all right we're going to finish the week
with a piece of good news here
so i know that the democrats would love
to have you continue to panic about
covet for the rest of time and in fact
you have the education secretary who
just came out and said we should
actually mandate covid19 vaccines in
schools this is miguel cardona he said
not only do i support it i'm encouraging
states to come with a plan to make sure
it happens i would like governors who
hold those decisions to make decisions
now that vaccines are fda approved
there's a reason we're not talking about
measles today it was a required
vaccination we put it behind us i do
believe at this point we need to be
moving forward yes the reason that we
are not talking about measles is because
meals foot measles is a childhood
disease it was not endemic among the
population
the basic notion that if you mandate
vaccinations for small children with
regard to cover that you're going to
wipe out covet is silly there's not a
single scientist who believes this is
the case no one believes we are getting
to zero covid
but now we're talking about mandating
for small children these vaccines which
again is one thing to say for adults who
have a higher risk that they ought to be
thinking about taking the vaccine
because the risks from covet outweigh
the risks from the vaccine but when
you're talking about the risks of cove
to small children the risks are so
unbelievably minute that you're talking
about gradations of risk and maybe a
little bit of long-term testing might be
a little bit better like we can barely
get the cdc and the fda to agree on who
should get booster shots at this point
who are adults
and here you have government actors
suggesting that we are going to mandate
vaccines for children with regard to
covenant 19 again with regards to a
disease that
kids are just not dying from in large
numbers
and in many years there have been more
deaths like half of the past 10 years
there have been more deaths from the flu
than there have been from covet over the
period of covid
and yet you have the democrats
continuing to push this stuff gavin
newsom the uh the once and future
governor of california he says that a
vaccine mandate is still on the table
for kids
we want to continue to be vigilant we
want to continue to lean in we still
have a lot of work to do i worry about a
winter surge and so yes it's now back on
the table
to get our kids vaccinated 12 to 17.
we're not seeing the numbers we're
seeing for other age cohorts
the decision will be made over the
course the next few days we have a lot
of partners with 1050 school districts
in the state of california the largest
school system in the united states but
it is true our health director said it
today that this is on the table it's
being debated uh and over the next few
days uh we will come out i'm sorry this
is this is ridiculous this is ridiculous
okay but i told you i'd end with some
good news here's the good news according
to the latest uk data you know other
countries actually have data we don't
bother to do data in the united states
we just have our fda and cdc pretty much
just pull out of their ass and they
don't have any rationale for it
okay here's the data from the uk you
ready long coveted symptoms are higher
in the control group than in the covid
positive group for young children at 12
to 16 weeks post-infection
so you're more likely to have long
coveted symptoms in a control group than
in the covet positive group for kids
post-infection not only that
the woman who created the oxford vaccine
now says that covet is unlikely to
mutate into a much deadlier deadlier
variant and will eventually just cause
something that looks like the common
cold
so there's your good news is that we are
pretty much at the end of this thing but
uh they're not gonna stop the panic
because the panic is how they get things
done
who's got two thumbs and wants you to
like and subscribe